the whole of the labor family had
devastated tonight joe cox has been
killed doing her duty doing her work as
a constituency MP she's somebody who
dedicated her life to human rights and
to justice she worked for anti-slavery
campaigns she worked for Oxfam and she
became an MP for the area where she was
born and grew up and loved in Parliament
she was respected across the whole house
somebody was a deep commitment and deep
passion for human rights and justice
sadly today she died she was killed on
the streets of her constituency doing
her duty as a local Member of Parliament
helping people she leaves behind a
husband a wonderful man who likewise
spends his life campaigning for human
rights and justice and she leaves behind
two young children two young children
who will never grow up to see them on
again they can be proud of what she was
they can proud of what she did and they
can be very proud of everything that she
stood for we come together at a time
like this we come together to support
the family and to mourn and reflect that
violence is not an answer violence is
not an answer to anything we need to
come together and express our deepest
condolences to Joe and her family we've
lost a wonderful woman we've lost a
wonderful member of parliament but our
democracy will go on her work will go on
as we mourn her memory will work in her
memory to achieve that better world she
spent her life trying to achieve